PROFESSOR.
GREAT TO SEE YOU TONIGHT, HAPPY
THANKSGIVING.
I HEAR THIS STUFF, AND I THINK
PEOPLE ARE OPERATING IN PARALLEL
UNIVERSES.
IF YOU DON'T LIKE TRUMP, THAT'S
YOUR PREROGATIVE, BUT YOU HAVE
TO MAKE A COHERENT ARGUMENT
BASED ON FACTS.
MOST OF THE FOLKS ON THE LEFT
ARE EMBITTERED, ANGRY AND
DELUSIONAL AT THIS POINT.
I ASK ABOUT THE TWILIGHT ZONE
BECAUSE THE SAME MEDIA OUTLETS
WHO FELL FOR THE RIDICULOUSLY
PHONY STEELE DOSSIER ARE NOW
EMBRACING THE FOUNDERS OF THE
FIRM BEHIND THE STEELE DOSSIER.
GLENN SIMPSON AND PETER FRISCH
ARE PROMOTING THEIR NEW BOOK AND
NBC GAVE THEM A LOT OF QUESTIONS
LIKE HOW DOES IT FEEL, WHAT'S
YOUR FAVORITE COLOR?
WATCH.
>> REPUBLICANS CONTROLLED
WASHINGTON FOR TWO YEARS AND
THEY USE THAT TIME TO
INVESTIGATE THE INVESTIGATORS.
AND DIG INTO US AND WASTE
ENORMOUS AMOUNTS OF MONEY TRYING
TO FIND SOMETHING ON US THAT
WOULD DISCREDIT US.
>> WE WEREN'T ABLE TO TALK ABOUT
THOSE THINGS FOR A LONG TIME AND
IN THE MEANTIME FACED A LOT OF
PRESSURE FROM REPUBLICANS IN
CONGRESS SPECIFICALLY THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE AND THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE.
>> Laura: I'M NOT SURE WHAT HE
MUMBLED AT THE END, HERE TO
RESPOND, DEVIN NUNES, RANKING
MEMBER OF THE HOUSE AND TELL
COMMITTEE AND LEE SMITH, AUTHOR
OF "THE PLOT AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT," FANTASTIC BOOK.
CONGRESSMAN, FUSION GPS ACTUALLY
RAN A CAMPAIGN AGAINST YOU IN
2018, WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT
THEIR WHINING AND MOANING?
THEY WERE MEAN TO US, THEY WERE
SO MEAN TO US AND THE KID GLOVE
TREATMENT THEY WERE GETTING AT
NBC?
>> IT'S TYPICAL, WHATEVER THEY
ACCUSE YOU OF DOING, THEY ARE
ACTUALLY DOING.
EVEN THE TITLE OF THEIR BOOK IS
HILARIOUS BECAUSE THEY ARE THE
ONES CONTINUING THE CRIMES.
I THINK PART OF WHAT THIS BOOK
IS ABOUT AS NOT TO SELL A BUNCH
OF COPIES, IT'S TO GET OUT AHEAD
OF THE LAWSUITS THAT ARE COMING.
THEY KNEW THROUGH DISCOVERY,
THEY WERE BEHIND ALL THE SMEARS
AND THAT IS WHAT IS CLEAR ABOUT
THE BOOK AND THAT IS GOING TO
COME OUT ON THE COURT CASES
ANYWAY.
>> Laura: WHAT TO AMERICANS
WATCHING TONIGHT HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND ABOUT THIS DUO AT
FUSION GPS?
YOU DOCUMENTED THIS BETTER THAN
ANYONE ABOUT WHAT WAS DONE
ESPECIALLY TO CONGRESSMAN
DEVIN NUNES WITHOUT WHOM
PRESIDENT TRUMP MIGHT NOT BE IN
THE CURRENT GOOD POSITION HE'S
IN BUT HIS WORK IS BEEN
UNBELIEVABLE.
WHAT DO PEOPLE HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND, IS THIS ANOTHER
CONSULTING GROUP OR SOMETHING
QUITE DIFFERENT?
>> AT SOMETHING QUITE DIFFERENT.
IF YOU LOOK AT THESE DIFFERENT
CLIPS ON NBC, SPEAKING WITH
CHUCK TODD AND WITH RACHEL
MADDOW, IT LOOKS LIKE A RANSOM.
IT LOOKS LIKE A HOSTAGE VIDEO
BECAUSE ALL OF THE MEDIA
ORGANIZATIONS, THEY WEREN'T JUST
TRICKED, THEY WERE COMPLICIT IN
WHAT IS GOING ON.
IF YOU LOOK AT THEIR FACES, THEY
HAVE TO PUT THEIR MESSAGE
THROUGH AND THE MEDIA IS GOING
TO TAKE IT AND THEY'RE GOING TO
WORK WITH THEM TO SHAPE THIS
NARRATIVE NOW WITH HOROWITZ.
VERY IMPORTANT FOR THEM TO GET
THIS MESSAGE OUT AND TRY TO
SHAPE IT.
>> Laura: IT IS VERY
NOTEWORTHY THAT THE FUSION GPS
MEMBERS WENT TO NBC FIRST.
THE HOSTS WOULD BEND OVER
BACKWARDS TO GIVE THEM AN
INTERVIEW STYLE FOOT RUB.
>> YOUR NEW BOOK IS CALLED
"CRIME IN PROGRESS" IT'S REALLY
GOOD.
I FEEL STEEPED IN THIS MATTER
AND I LEARNED SOMETHING ON EVERY
PAGE.
>> WHAT KIND OF TOLL HAS THIS
TAKEN ON YOU PERSONALLY?
>> THE BOOK, NO MATTER WHAT YOU
THINK ABOUT THE STEELE DOSSIER
COME IF YOU TALK ABOUT IT, YOU
SHOULD READ THIS BOOK.
>> Laura: WHY NBC?
A FEW YEARS AGO, LEE WROTE ABOUT
A CONNECTION BETWEEN A SPECIFIC
NBC REPORTER AND FUSION GPS,
EXPLAIN THAT BRIEFLY.
>> THIS IS ABOUT KEN DELANEY AT
NBC AND HE WAS ATTACKING WILLIAM
BROWDER AS PART OF AN OPERATION
ON BEHALF OF THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT.
HE APPEARED TO BE RECITING
TALKING POINTS PROVIDED BY
FUSION GPS.
THERE ARE EXTENSIVE CONNECTIONS
BETWEEN FUSION GPS AND THE
ENTIRE MEDIA AND NBC IS
CERTAINLY A PART OF THAT.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN NUNES AT
THIS POINT WE KNOW THE
JERRY NADLER CREW IS GOING TO
GET TWO WEEKS OF THEIR OWN
WHATEVER THEY'RE GOING TO END UP
DOING WITH THIS IMPEACHMENT
NONSENSE.
WHAT DO YOU EXPECT TO HAPPEN?
I'M GOING TO SAY THIS TO
EVERYONE WHO HAS MISSED THE LAST
FEW MINUTES OF THE SHOW -- HE'S
THREATENING TO PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES WITH UNSPECIFIED
PENALTIES IF HE DOESN'T SHOW UP
TO TESTIFY.
THIS IS WHERE WE HAVE GOTTEN.
>> I CANNOT IMAGINE HOW A
CONSTITUTIONAL HEARING NEXT WEEK
ABOUT THE CONSTITUTIONALITY OF
IMPEACHMENT, HOW THAT IS GOING
TO BE ANY BETTER FOR THEM THAN
THE LAST TWO WEEKS WHEN THEY HAD
DUD AFTER DUD AFTER DUD OF
WITNESSES.
NADLER, EVIDENTLY HE HAS BEEN
FOUND BECAUSE THE GUY HAS BEEN
MISSING SINCE BEFORE THE SUMMER
TIME, NOBODY HAS SEEN HIM.
THEY RIPPED HIM OFF THE STAGE SO
I CAN'T IMAGINE -- MY GUESS IS
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE LIKE ONE
HEARING NEXT WEEK AND THEY WILL
FOOT THE FOLLOWING WEEK.
I CAN'T IMAGINE THEY WILL LEAVE
HIM UP FOR MULTIPLE HEARINGS AND
HAVE ANOTHER WERE ALL THE
NETWORKS COVER THESE GUYS, IT
WILL DRIVE THE NUMBERS EVEN
LOWER THAN THEY ARE TODAY.
>> Laura: HAVING YOU BOTH ON
TOGETHER IS A TREAT BECAUSE
CONGRESSMAN, I REMEMBER WHEN YOU
WERE BEING SMEARED WHEN THEY
WERE CLAIMING YOU WERE
CONFLICTED OUT OF THE WHOLE
RUSSIA THING, THEY WERE LYING
ABOUT THAT I DON'T KNOW HOW
LONG, THAT'S WHEN I WAS STILL
DOING MY RADIO SHOW AND THEN IT
WAS ALL THIS MADE-UP NONSENSE.
YOU TOOK IT UPON YOURSELF TO
WRITE ABOUT THIS AND TO EXPLAIN
IT IN A WAY -- I SOUND LIKE I'M
SUCKING UP TO YOU, IT'S SO
IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE TO
UNDERSTAND IT'S NOT JUST WHAT
YOU READ IN THE HEADLINES, YOU
HAVE TO DIG INTO THE FACTS OF
WHAT THEY DO TO GOOD PEOPLE TO
TRY TO RIPPED THEM TO SHREDS.
IT'S CRITICAL, MEANWHILE THIS
PETER FRISCH GUY WAS SPEAKING ON
"MEET THE PRESS" ABOUT THE
PARALLELS BETWEEN RUSSIA AND
IMPEACHMENT, I'VE GOT TO GET YOU
BOTH QUICKLY ON THIS, WATCH.
>> I'M SITTING HERE TODAY AT THE
END OF 2019, DOES ANYONE DOUBT
THE DONALD TRUMP WOULD BE
CAPABLE OF WORKING WITH A
FOREIGN GOVERNMENT TO AFFECT THE
POLITICAL PROCESS IN THIS
COUNTRY?
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THE HOUSES
LOOKING AT RIGHT NOW.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN NUNES,
QUICKLY YOUR THOUGHTS.
>> THEY ARE THE ONES THAT WENT
TO FOREIGNERS, THEY TOOK MONEY
FROM THE DEMOCRATS AND WENT TO
UKRAINIANS AND RUSSIANS TO DIG
UP DIRT ON TRUMP.
THESE GUYS ARE A COMPLETE JOKE,
THEY ARE RACKETEERING OPERATION
AND THEY NEED TO BE SHUT DOWN.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN NUNES, I
KNOW YOU'RE GOING TO GET A TIE
BACK ON WHEN YOU COME BACK TO
WORK.
HE'S ALWAYS AT THE EXPO -- YOUR
BACK ON.
YOU'RE ALWAYS AT THIS EXPO, WHAT
IS AT?
EVERY TIME I HAVE YOU ON.
THERE'S TRUCKS IN THE BACK.
>> IT'S BY MY HOUSE AND I GOT
NICE COLORFUL BACKGROUNDS AND
MUSEUMS.